welcome to this video playing jewel
jewel packs 70m jewel pecs whatever hmm
the Philippines let's see I'm Sicilian
now I can hmm you six gives white some
extra options but ok let's play the open
it's always a little bit demanding for
me because my experience there is like
very limited I think in tournament chess
the open Selena maybe have played like
two or three times in my life so it's
kind of yeah freestyling for me I mean I
know some some some stuff obviously from
studying black openings but it's not
like a huge expert yeah that's one liner
Knight g4 as a threat i think i have to
do this mmm where black can play Bishop
c5 now I think and then there is f4 ok
it's not playing Bishop c5 when I came
f4 is part of whites plan anyway and you
normally take with the pawn I think
because Luke c1 will gain useful time on
the Queen I really don't think that this
is so great for what he did ok he wants
to move the Queen again it seems uh-huh
so I can go a five or f5 yeah f5s the
way to go he basically I think has to
play me five and now I'm trying for
control over d5 just wonder how to do it
exactly like here
for ya this is okay for Bishop g5 Bishop
g5 takes Knight to g5 this is what I
want to do b4 night a fawn has Knight b6
coming it's also not really great no he
is also far behind in development having
moved him his night here tons of times
Knight e5 Jake's d3 and so on then those
Queen moves okay he wants to put the
bishop on c6
that's it's quite decent idea let's
start with that if he goes Bishop c6 now
as i'm going to i can't i can try to try
to destroy spawn structure checks it and
then I g3 to h5 may be this tough tough
position tough position it's not as
clear-cut as I thought maybe add
something better where I'm am unsure
this looks bit strange for black but not
necessarily bad yeah exactly um so night
to h5 film now if you take the exchange
I will get f64 control over d5 ok so any
good way here mmm roxy two are not
I wonder about Quincy for Quincy for 2h
forward it's not really helping me much
okay at least he cannot so easily play
d5 maybe he can but it it opens up his
own King position
champ is got the gphone what a weird
game
contending do you form I wanted to get
out of this check as well
93 that was very time consuming black
provoking this
I'm thinking maybe I can yeah let's do
this I don't want him to play rook c3 if
he takes the exchange I definitely have
a nice structure now d 5 is impossible
and I have ideas queen d three rookie
one things like that his bishop is kind
of a tricky piece it's it looks active
but it's not clear what it is doing and
sometimes I maybe be it may be able to
play my lucky I am queen here where is
he going now if he goes to the Kings
side the bishop is not doing pretty much
anything and here I'm threatening queen
age six now and this is very substantial
yeah I can take him I only one now good
it is takes Knight age five you can
sacrifice unfortunately
I'm not sure about this rook takes g4
Queen age 60 page four okay I am I have
to go for that I only have one minute
something left maybe check rook takes
you for I know this one I good defense a
phone for Queen txt hot check okay I
cannot really allow that I had to cover
your form but now Bishop e3 bull ok not
it's not coming
Queen age six this point
it's always check it's very important so
that he has no Queen III stuff
now so some tricks awesome I think I'm
winning now I mean probably on time
anyway with black for effects on time a
tricky business very complicated i was
certainly outplayed somehow it was weird
i mean this this really should be
excellent but i didn't exploit it maybe
f5 wasn't timed right no I have to go to
be three yeah that's much stronger
listen this this this square wasn't
really on my radar also see 2 nite c 2
was also interesting in order to have
this idea yeah i was i was going here
because i thought that this might be an
idea to fight for the d5 square but it's
it is just better to try to go here and
i have this ideas like we go here I'm
ship t7 interesting hmm difficult this
is also interesting normally the night
is not very well placed there but here
there's this idea maybe this now trying
to get this in gym yet all of a sudden
wasn't great no I would take taking this
is it's not good am i can i can eat Jack
take your first because this is all the
static yeah so that's not good here be
three yeah here black is just better
in some ways black is better yeah here
okay i didn't i didn't mind to do this
this is probably the strongest anyway
here yeah probably this is not really
enough young but not easy to play queen
bee sixes the comp move here i have a
look g5 defense and this seems to be not
working due to exactly what he played
yes yeah he was sort of stumbling into
this this trick here black is completely
winning yeah and here white is totally
winning of him he does he has to play
Queen a to him with the counter-attack
the thing is that this is really only
just one check and then I'm losing I
don't have something like that it's just
check made jello and then he gave it
away with 30 seconds on the clock there
was some lucky winner definitely yeah so
it was really a very delicate situation
here out of the opening so this is a
crucial moment how long did it take me
to play that 15 seconds at least I
didn't play it instantly but I thought
92 g3 is the way to go but it's really
better on be three asti too because it's
more related to the Queen side in a way
huh interesting this is this is really
much better him oh the comp even gives
this move which is interesting directly
invading nice
check check comsys wide wins here rook
FC one route 87 rook 167 coming well
yeah that's dangerous yeah I am miss
chances in the opening definitely
alright thanks for watching